all right let me try to convince you
another way you're going to need to draw
be a table of values right now we'll do
it like so it's going to have to be
fairly large unity for rose on it and I
think if we do one two three four five
six seven eight columns that should
hopefully be enough to convince us okay
so i'm going to go for rose and eight
columns
this is useful
make you first call it a bit wider than
the others
okay may you see the table of values
before excuse me you draw loads of
tables of values before but this is kind
of a table of values on steroids right
because usually you just have the X the
inputs and the y or the f of X which is
the outputs ok and then you've actually
about any coordinates ok but he won't
want to do is I don't just want to have
one set of coordinates and one graph I
want to have a whole bunch of cord so i
can compare what's going on all right
now i'm going to give you a bit of a
mood because we actually know a whole
bunch of these values and i'm going to
make a little bit for you so you don't
have to machine these all out ok let's
think about our original our original
ground now remember you told me the
roots of that original graph x squared
plus 5x plus 6 i've done in black so
it's a bit different from the others the
roots of it are negative 3 negative 2 ok
negative 3 negative 2 what that means if
is if your x values are negative 3
negative 2 if you stick the vin to hear
you'll get zero that's what it means for
them to be the x intercepts so therefore
without any calculation I'm just going
to put those in ok x equals 0 x equals 0
try f of X is equal to 0 in both those
cases and if you like you can go ahead
you can put it minus 2 in here for
instance negative 2 is going to become
4-10 plus 6 and accounts vodka Jazeera
you can do the same with a different ok
so you're a parent 0 is there let's do
an easy number like negative 1 ok
negative 1 if I put negative 1 into here
help me out I'm going to get one take
away 5 which is negative 4 plus 6
negative 4 plus 6 is to write to now
because the parabolas are all
symmetrical right and you can see these
are kind of like the middle parts of the
parabola if this is too then this is
going to be true as well if you want you
can go ahead and you can test it out you
can stick negative 4 in better but I'm
not going to bother because I already
did it about half an hour ago and you'll
get that you'll get this symmetry
happening all right x equals 0 you also
do this one this is the widest out
what's the y intercept of
original rap it's six right you can see
because this is 0 this is you're just
going to flip the six right and I'll
just help you out you get these two more
values over here okay now what about the
other two what happens when we compare
them right well let's have a look it up
let's have a look at f of X plus 2 1st
that's what we did earlier straight- for
when you put in x equals negative 4 you
actually already know what's going to
happen when you put in x equals negative
4 for this crap because it's am it's a
root right so what will it be equal to
if it's a root adds up zero okay you've
already done that one um okay for the
sake of making sure we know what the
value is let's try negative 3 now we're
popping it into this guy here okay with
proper use video so if i do negative 3
okay help me out negative 3 squared
that's nine this is going to become
minus 27 right because I'm negative so
nine take away 27 is negative 18
negative 18 plus 20 this sounds like to
write huh one more time negative to you
too that's going to become 4-18 what's
four take away 18 that's negative 14
plus 20 negative 14 plus 20 years huh
how much convincing do you need that's
going to be 12 that's going to be 20
that's an obvious one do you see why
because 00 20 let's just cook and do
this one this is gonna be one plus 9
plus 20 which is 30 and this one's going
to be 4 plus 18 22 plus 29 be 42 okay
all right so there are my numbers right
but what's going on here right what's
the difference between our original
function and this guy have a look at the
numbers if you've got another color you
can see everything has been moved to the
left but you set 6 went to the left 2
units and this two went to left 2 units
and this 0 went to the left 2 units
and it's the same with every other
number that's on there if we had a wider
table of values you'd see the ball
shifting over to the left translating to
the left okay so this is our to the left
function okay all right now I'm not
going to ask you to uh to crunch out the
numbers but I think you can guess what's
going to happen when we evaluate these
numbers down here right you get your
calculator out excuse me and you're
going to get something like let's see
for a memory I think we're gonna have
zeros here you canna 26 12 to 6 but you
go ahead you test your values to make
sure that I'm not just making this up
okay but everything is doing the
opposite isn't it right it's all moving
to the to the right so do you see what's
happening here right let's draw a
conclusion and then i'm going to show
you my last my third way or try to
convince is this is the case okay let me
try and generalize when i do this kind
of thing right let's let's take this as
our example f of X minus a right how is
it different to our original f of X
right f of X minus a is the same as f of
X in every single way look the graphs
are identical right except except it's
been translated or shifted either of
those words to find in fact i'm going to
write but it's being translated or
shifted now in the examples that I gave
you concrete examples I chose the number
two but there's no reason I could have
chosen three or four or five or five
hundred right it just would have gone
further either of those directions right
so it's been translated how far for
these it was two units so if i put the
number a in there whatever number a
happens to be it won't be true
you'll be a units right do you see that
whatever value it is it's been shifted
or translated a units which direction
okay so if if I'm if I've got ya it's
almost opposite isn't this is the
counter intuitive thing that I was
talking about right when you get X minus
a you go to the right that's a bit weird
because on here negative seems to me
that way to the left right but look
we've kind of like empirically proven it
almost by experimentation look what you
try these values out it doesn't go to
the left it goes over and hear the right
it's got no choice okay a units to the
right now the great thing about this
only put a big box around this the great
thing about this is that still works
even in this case I don't have to write
a separate rule for this guy right
because i can rewrite this guy as f of X
take away now if I've got two plus two
here right and I want to take away
something which is the same as adding to
what do you take away from something
which is the same as adding dad soon as
if you take away if you take away
negative elmar right because we know a
double negatives they cancel right so
what does this mean what does this mean
this means f of X minus that is the same
as f of X but it's been translated now
Marcus it's been translated negative 2
units to the right so to the rights go
in that way but I've gone negative 2 in
the opposite direction which we would
usually say is to the left okay does
that make sense when you see this X
minus something it means go that way if
you see X plus something it means go
that way the opposite the way that you
would think okay for those of you who
are learning to drive it's a bit like
when you're reversing okay and you turn
the wheel the opposite way you're
supposed to do because that's the way
the car is going to go all right
it's the same with these functions